E
THESE RECONNAISSANCE FLIGHTS
THERE ABOVE THE BLACK SEA
UNDETERRED.
LET'S BRING IN CNN PENTAGON
CORRESPONDENT OREN LIEBERMANN
AND BRING BACK RETIRED COLONEL
CEDRIC LAYTON.
FIRST, OREN, HEADLINES OUT OF
WHAT WE JUST HEARD.
>> GENERAL PAT RYDER HIT HOME ON
THE POINT THAT THE U.S. SEIZED
THIS AS INTERNATIONAL AIR SPACE
AND THE U.S. WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THERE WITH SURVEILLANCE
DRONES AND OTHER ASSETS AS IT
SEES FIT.
THE U.S. HAS EVERY RIGHT TO DO
THAT.
BRIGADIER GENERAL PAT RIDER
HITTING HOME ON THAT POINT.
THEN ASKED, WHY RELEASE THE
VIDEO, AND HE SAID, THE U.S.
RELEASE VIDEOS WHEN IT SEES FIT,
AFTER IT GOES THROUGH A
DECLASSIFICATION PROCESS.
WE WERE TRACKING THIS VIDEO AS
IT WAS MOVING THROUGH THAT
DECLASSIFICATION PROCESS,
ESSENTIALLY.
BUT IT ALSO UNDERSCORED THAT THE
ACCOUNT OF THE U.S. WAS THE ONE
THAT MORE ACCURATELY DEPICTED
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
THIS AFTER THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S., PRETTY
QUICKLY AFTER THIS ALL CAME OUT,
DENIED THAT THERE WAS ANY
CONTACT, PHYSICAL CONTACT
BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN AND FIGHTER
JETS AND THE DRONES.
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THE U.S. TO
PUT THIS OUT THERE TO MAKE CLEAR
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED HERE,
VICTOR AND BIANNA.
AND IT WAS ALSO NOTE THAT THE
BRIGADIER GENERAL SAID THAT NO
APOLOGY WAS ASKED FOR, AND NONE
WAS GIVEN.
NOT THAT WE EXPECT ONE FROM THE
RUSSIANS.
BUT WE DID SEE WHETHER THIS WAS
A NEW TRAM.
THIS MORE AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR BY
THE RUPGS MILITARY AND MORE OF
THESE INTERCEPTS NOT SOME IN THE
BLACK SEA, BUT IN THE MIDDLE
EAST AND IN SYRIA.
HE SORT OF DEFLECTED THAT
QUESTION.
SO I'M HOPING YOU WITH YOUR
EXPERTISE CAN WEIGH IN AND GIVE
US YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK THAT THAT
IS THE CASE, BIANNA.
THE KEY THINGS HERE IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS GO IN WAVES.
SOMETIMES THEY WILL BE MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
INTERCEPTING RECONNAISSANCE
FLIGHTS.
WITH THEIR MORE AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH, THAT ALL CHANGES.
THE RULE BOOK BECOMES A
DIFFERENT ONE.
AND WHAT THE RUSSIANS END UP
DOING IS THEY END UP TAKING VERY
AGGRESSIVE MANEUVERS AGAINST
MANNED AND UNMANNED AREAL
VEHICLES.
AND SO THAT CAN HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES, NOT
ONLY IN THE BLACK SEA AREA, BUT
IN THE BALTIC AND OTHER AREAS
ALONG THE RUSSIAN BORDER.
>> COLONEL, THIS DRONE IS NOW
UNDER ABOUT A MILE OF WATER.
IS THIS THE RETRIEVAL WORTH THE
WORK FOR EITHER THE U.S., WHICH
SAYS THAT IT'S UNLIKELY THEY'LL
RETRIEVE IT, OR FOR THE
RUSSIANS, WHO HAVE SOME ASSETS
IN THE AREA AND SAY THEY WILL GO
AFTER THAT DRONE?
>> YEAH, IT'S GOING TO BE HARD
FOR EITHER SIDE TO DO THIS,
VICTOR.
THE RUSSIANS WILL LOOK AT IT AS
GETTING A PROPAGANDA COUP IF
THEY CAN GET THIS UP IN A
PROFITABLE FASHION.
IF THEY CAN PULL IT UP AND SAY,
LOOK WHAT WE HAVE, THAT WILL BE
A PROPAGANDA THING FOR THEM.
AS FAR AS THE U.S. IS CONCERNED,
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
GOOD IF WE COULD TAKE IT BACK,
IF WE COULD GET THE PIECES AND
PARTS THAT HAVE CRASHED INTO THE
BLACK SEA AND SAFEGUARD THEM
FROM THE RUSSIANS.
BUT IT IS NOT ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT WE DO SO.
BASICALLY, WITH THE RENDERING
NULL AND VOID OF THE SOFTWARE
THAT WAS ONBOARD, IT REALLY
TAKES OUT ALL OF THE
INTELLIGENCE PARTS THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO THE RUSSIANS AND SO IF
THAT IS TRUE, THEY WERE ABLE TO
IN ESSENCE ZERO ALL THE DATA
THAT WAS IMPORTANT AND IT'S NOT
THAT IMPORTANT THAT WE GET T